[Music]
hey
everybody it's tuesday and we're here
talking about another movie you seem
like way too far
over there not too far over yeah yeah
look at you what are you doing over you
keep moving this [ __ ] too
i don't i can't see this is not there's
no uniformity in this [ __ ] as far as i
can move
that's what it is yeah i can't move any
further than that because that's the
end of the day put some tape on there
like you do like you do on a [ __ ]
movie
or in a tv studio to show exactly where
the sh
where the where the chair legs go well
sometimes i move the chair because you
leave the chair there and then when i
back my chair up it knocks it over see
how this [ __ ] goes she can twist that
[ __ ] around on me so it's my fault
what is here why is there everything's
here the lighting is [ __ ] up and
i see we don't have our reflections oh
cause that was yeah cause i had
i was in there earlier
i didn't actually i didn't realize that
that made that much oh yeah oh yeah i
gotta get that [ __ ]
there's a light and it's bouncing off
gotta get that soft closet door and i
had the closet open because i was in
there like recording earlier
gotta get that soft [ __ ] bounce
yeah somebody said are you using your
new camera it looks different no it was
just because we didn't have the light
bouncing
yeah that's why um all right so
i got a different color going on back
there too oh and that was yeah we
changed it to green for the halloween we
were gonna try
we changed them to orange but you
couldn't really tell they were orange no
they just looked white
they just kind of looked whitish or
yellowish and i was like man so we
changed it to green and you forgot to
change it back actually i think the
green looks pretty good
yeah it looks all right i mean you can't
really just you turn spock's knees green
yeah see it's got like behind me like a
halo
like my energy that's your aura my aura
i haven't got one i've just got it's
blue because i'm
it's blue black-hearted and yellow yeah
that's right
all right so we're talking about another
movie today
here's another one that uh just dropped
on shutter
now i am obviously an idiot because
i was about three quarters of the way
through this movie before i realized it
was a sequel to something
and i should have realized it to start
with okay
because the movie it's indonesian okay
and it's called
may the devil take you to but not to
like
the number two like t-o-o like also and
so it didn't really occur to me that
this was a sequel but then when i saw
like the poster that had the indonesian
title on it
um it was actually like whatever that
i'm not even gonna attempt to pronounce
because i don't want to offend anybody
with my
terrible pronunciation but it was called
essentially
whatever the title was chapter two so
this is a sequel which explains a lot
now
i don't think that you necessarily have
to have seen the first one because i
figured out what was going on but i
think probably
um you would get into the story faster
like if you knew
what had happened in the past and like
who these characters were like in
relation to one another
but like i said you don't have to have
seen it because they do give you enough
information that you can like figure it
out but it doesn't come to like halfway
through three quarters of the way
through
yeah i got to say uh before before we
get off into this
the movie looked good yeah uh it had a
lot of action in it
there's something about these indonesian
movies uh i'm i'm digging them
all right but this particular one was
kind of samey
yeah i mean it's a it's a possession
movie yeah um
and you can tell that the director whose
name is teemo e gianto
maybe i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing
that right either sorry um
but uh you can tell he's a big sam remy
fan yeah this is not a comedy
um but and it's not it's a possession
movie but it's not like an
exorcist style possession movie there's
not like priests and all that kind of
[ __ ]
um but there is some of that in it but
there is like a lot of sam raimi like
gore a lot of kind of
um you know camera shots that are kind
of like
evil dead-ish it's got some good
practical effects
mixed with some questionable digital
effects but it doesn't really matter
it's within the context of
of a lower budget movie it was
acceptable
you know i'm thinking of the fire you
know the cg fire
it's hard to do cg fire um
it was it was a it was a decent
flick yeah it was a decent flick don't
expect to see
anything brand new or innovative or or
mind-blowing
you sit down yet you sit down you're
drinking it's uh
saturday night you want to see your
[ __ ] monster movie
it does deliver on that yeah it's pretty
action-packed
and there is like a lot of gore there's
a lot of ghosts and monsters and like
i could have think i think i could have
had a little bit more
humor in it yeah because it's not fun
it's not funny
right and i think it would have been a
little bit better with
because some of the [ __ ] that happens is
[ __ ] through the roof it
you know it strains credulity you know
what i mean yeah there's some pretty
wild chicken
you might as well go to the sam raimi
root and and just lean into it and go
yeah it's just ridiculous
i like that better it's more honest and
you and it
gives you a different tone you know what
i mean is that
you're not supposed to be believing that
this is actual
yeah you know what i mean so that's what
i think it should have done other than
that
it was it was a workmanlike movie yeah
this was decent and like i said i'd be
interested to know because like i said i
didn't really figure out until
like halfway or three-quarters of the
way through that this was actually a
sequel
and then i was like i looked on i'm
pretty sure shutter has the first one
too so i'd be interested to know
because i was reading a review of it and
the girl that was reviewing it had the
same experience as me she was like i
didn't realize it was a sequel i watched
the second one and then i was like oh it
is a sequel so they went she went back
and watched the first one
and then watched the second one again
and she's like the second one is much
much better
when you've seen the first one you don't
have to have seen the first one
but it helps because you kind of get
into because you have like a bunch
apparently you have a bunch of new
characters in this
but a couple of characters are carried
over from the first
movie um and they kind of get thrown
into a new situation so basically what
the story
is is that at the very beginning
um there's this girl named dewey and
there's like this other
girl named uh gaddis i think is her name
and basically some bad [ __ ] happens it
seems like she's they don't say it
outright but
maybe she's possessed by a demon or a
demon or a ghost or
violent ghost is haunting her she has
like bruises all over and [ __ ] like that
um and the friends her friends are kind
of like they don't really believe her
that was 15 years ago it's like he's
gone blah blah
and then it turns out that uh debbie the
friend she gets like horribly brutally
murdered like in an obviously very
supernatural sort of way
so then you cut to this other character
named alfie and her daughter nara
now these two i didn't know it at the
time but these two
were are carrying over from the for or
at least alfie carries over
from the first film because i guess the
first movie was about her
and her dad and her dad like summoning a
demon like
because he wanted like a witch to like
give him a bunch of money or something
like that
and accidentally summon a demon like you
do sometimes happens to everybody you
know
um so apparently that was the first
movie and she's back for the second one
she has a daughter now
and she basically gets kidnapped by
uh gaddis and all of her friends because
they're like hey you've been through
this devil [ __ ] before
so we think all of us are um
orphans like we all grew up in the same
orphanage
and the guy that ran the orphanage was
like this abusive [ __ ]
and we killed him and we think that he's
back and we think that you need to help
us deal with it
and then chaos ensues
so like i said this is um you know it's
nothing new
like in the possession genre it's not
like i said it doesn't have
you know like an exorcist or a or a
western possession
kind of thing where like the church guy
comes and like sprays holy water
everywhere and
like it's much more like sam raimi evil
dead
type possession you know what i mean
it's much more that kind of thing
so it's a little bit more um i guess
original in that regard but i mean if
you're into possession flicks if you
like indonesian flicks actually we've
reviewed like a few indonesian movies
uh on the show quite recently and i've
actually really enjoyed them didn't we
watch that one that was called i think
it was called empetogor
um that was actually real yeah that was
about the cult right yeah i think it
was a good one look i gotta say that one
was better than this one um yeah i'll
agree with you on that one
but they're different kind of movies i
guess this one it's just a different
kind of horror movie
yeah i'm not i'm generally not like a
big
movie person it's like i'll watch them
think evil dead
but this this but not a comedy but not
but not a horror comedy just like a
straight [ __ ]
yeah a straight horror movie that's done
in the style it's kind of like a style
evil dead like it's kind of like it's
like evil dead and they're trying to get
you to buy into it
like it's like it's real uh and that
it's all serious
yeah which i think was a mistake but
okay i mean there's a lot
there's quite a bit of gore in this like
i said there's quite a bit of
demons it's real i don't want to say
it's like
over the top it's not as over the top as
evil dead
but it does have like a lot of people um
screaming
it does have a lot of like kind of
out there like demon [ __ ] i did like a
few of the like when one of the
possessed
chicks was trying to get into the room
where the little girl was
and she was like holding on to the top
of the door and then she was like
thumping on the door with her feet like
really like i thought that was really
cool the way that was done
another thing is i have to consider is i
have to consider my
age you know what i'm talking about
maybe if i was
in my teens i would have appreciated
this
more with the serious tone you know what
i mean maybe it would have scared me
more
at my age if it's got a comedic [ __ ]
element to it it's more enjoyable
yeah uh just because i don't buy you
this [ __ ] anyway yeah i mean you're not
gonna scare me so you might as well
amuse me
that's the way i look at it yeah now you
can scare me in a different way
like gross me the [ __ ] out or repel me
you don't talk about it
i can i can you that's you can do that
but that might piss me off actually i
may not enjoy that
there's only one movie in recent history
that kind of [ __ ] disturbed me that i
did enjoy and that'd have been like
human centipede
yeah that was [ __ ] nasty but i didn't
like that
yeah but i did like that movie but i
wouldn't watch it again
yeah that's one of those movies where
it's like well you kind of had to see it
yeah because
you know everybody had to see it yeah
it's just one of those things but we're
not going to watch that [ __ ] again man
right now well yeah there's some it's
interesting because yeah there's some
horror movies that
are just like even if they're over the
top gory or something even like
something like dead alive
which is just even though it's just
completely over the top and completely
disgusting
but it's still really fun and so it's
really rewatchable
with human centipede you're also feeling
bad for him you're like oh
well yeah exactly well yeah because you
can imagine
what would happen if you were in that
situation yeah yeah that that
that kind of [ __ ] you know what i
mean but but but to the movie's credit i
didn't get pissed off at it
yeah yeah i'm talking about i couldn't
like not like i'm gonna go oh [ __ ] i
ain't watching this [ __ ] anymore you
know
i didn't do that i wanted to see what
was gonna happen and then after it was
over i was like damn
everyone's gonna get their mouths pooped
into yes [ __ ] man
spoiler but you can kind of imagine
some [ __ ] crazy evil scientist coming
up with some [ __ ] like that
some [ __ ] perverted evil scientist
yeah with some kind of scat fetish or
something
you know what's funny like i i actually
wrote a short story
before a human had centipede even came
out about
a dude that was like a um circus
performer
and he had like a half brother like
growing out of his back yeah and they
had an act where the guy would like eat
the [ __ ] out of his
thing and then like he would like throw
it back up and yeah yeah yeah it's like
well well i i wrote it because i wanted
to see if i could just write like i said
i want to write something just like the
grossest [ __ ] that i can think of
and because i had read this story and i
can't remember who wrote it
but i read i had read this story about
this guy
who like was keeping his wife in the
cellar and like he would always like
make her
he would like eat corn and then he'd
poop and he'd make her like lick his
butt and everything like insanity
and i was just kind of like well if
something's gonna gross me out it has to
be poop related or vomit related
um because blood and gore and stuff like
that doesn't bother me so it's like so i
wrote that and it's like now even i was
reading it for like the audiobook and i
kept having to stop to gag
even though i wrote it yeah
they're talking about the sequel to
human centipede i saw the sequel but i
think i only saw like the first 15
minutes i got it looks like it was going
to be pretty good
i got interrupted and i never i never
finished it i think i've just seen like
pieces of them i don't think i've ever
like sat down and watched the whole
thing straight black and white
yeah yeah yeah it's black and white i've
just seen bits
i never got to finish it but yeah
something like that the
the ironic thing is that if i'm gonna
really really
love a horror movie um i actually kind
of want it to make me feel like [ __ ] and
like i never want to watch it again
because then it's like successful yeah
cause i was like that's a horror movie
all right i
never want to watch that [ __ ] ever again
you know what i'm saying because it
really like bothered me so much
and it happens less and less but it
still does happen every now and then
that i'm just like ah no thank you
but as i said if it's gonna gross me out
it usually has to be like poop related i
don't usually i don't see anything like
i don't see anything like graphically
like bloody that
grosses me out ever i don't think you
know i'm talking about
human centipede to do is jacking it with
sandpaper i didn't know that was
happening in it
oh yeah i kind of remember that gotta go
back and see it i gotta finish it i
guess
yeah that sounds like fun anything else
you want to say about this movie um
i don't think oh zach's just said
hereditary is my favorite movie now and
i also never want to watch it again yeah
same uh that's actually the one that i
was thinking of that movie like just
it just really really bothered me yeah
and it's like i want to watch it again
because i feel like there's so much [ __ ]
that i missed because there's like all
this hidden [ __ ] that happened in the
beginning like all the [ __ ] in the
background but it's like every time i
think about watching it again i get
anxiety
and i'm just like i don't because it
made me feel so so
shitty for like a week or two after i
saw it i was like i don't want to feel
like that again but
it was it was like a brilliant movie um
but yeah so
is that all we had to say on the subject
they were talking about the election
uh today is a big election day it's no
doubt it's gonna be like
the super bowl of all elections and
uh the whole world is watching and uh i
know some of you guys are gonna
some of you guys are [ __ ] messaging
me mega was messing private who's gonna
win
look all you gotta do is look at florida
and ohio
if you win florida after out of the
last 27 elections whoever won
except for one and that was jfk i think
they said
everyone who won florida in the past 27
elections except for one
uh won the election if you win florida
and ohio you're unbeatable
and uh just just watch those two states
you'll see i i can i got a pretty good
idea
that it's gonna be trump but there's no
way of knowing until
until they're you know until it starts
coming in you you'll have a real good
idea
uh in around by 11 o'clock 10 11 o'clock
central time or uh
eastern time you'll know about 10 by
about 10 or 11.
well i mean that's all projection from
exit polls
no it's early votes also well that too
but they don't start
they don't start counting all those
until the polls close right but you know
so it might be a few days before they
know
i don't think so they're going to try to
stretch it out but i don't think that
that's i don't think they're going to be
allowed i mean it's always been most of
the ones i remember
it's always been like there's like three
or four states that are trying to say oh
no we're going to take weeks to figure
it out and you know we're telling votes
counted
but that's not enough states that are
going to be doing that if the other ones
all call it and they're
and and you know there's good problem
and if trump did well
then you won't it won't matter if those
it won't matter if trump lose he can
concede
those states and they'll go right to a
thing
there's there's propaganda going on in
mind games
but i think we'll you'll know by tonight
yeah well like i said you'll know by
tonight because you see the thing is is
that
i think it's only four states that are
that are saying that no we're gonna take
days and days and you know they're gonna
be throwing ballots into the back door
or whatever
or they're gonna try to just slow down
the cow
but all trump has to do is concede to
those states
and that'll that'll put a damper on that
it's okay you gotta
that's probably what he would do because
i think he's gonna win enough in all the
other ones
but like we don't know we just have to
see just have to say
yeah i'm like yeah it's gonna be like
the super bowl though
i'm not gonna worry about it you know
what i don't watch it i love i'm gonna
have a drink i'm gonna sit in there
[ __ ]
because i like the [ __ ] commentary
it's just kind of like it reminds me of
pro wrestling it reminds me of like
when we used to have hurricanes and like
my grandmother would just like sit here
and watch like the hurricane hurricane
like for days and i'm like dude yeah
it's like two days before my grandma
used to do that too she'd be on the way
i both
like i'll figure it out tomorrow i'll
watch tomorrow my grandmother in
mississippi
her whole world changed when they had
that [ __ ] radar channel
yeah like the weather channel yeah it
wasn't even it was the weather channel
that's right
yeah and um you could pick it up i think
even without cable because i don't think
she had cable
and she would just put it on that
channel yeah and
watch the [ __ ] radar yep when it
first started it was like something off
of an atari
that's how few pixels there were on the
damn thing and they would be playing
music and she's sitting there just
watching the [ __ ] hurricane oh it's
going to be a big one
oh here it comes well the thing well the
thing about it too is that the
hurricanes i mean
when when they start talking about it in
florida it's like way over by [ __ ]
africa and it's like a week away
and it's like they'd have no [ __ ]
ideas yeah it could here
probably won't win like no point
worrying about it now winds of 180 miles
an hour what's coming
yeah yeah everybody i remember the whole
rigger yeah see my grandma did that it's
like a
oh lord oh my god
oh lord here it comes
lordy lordy i mean i don't know i guess
they didn't have anything better to do
it's like i got better [ __ ] to do oh i
mean
all right so anyway this movie's on
shutter if it sounds like it's good i
think the first one is on there as well
if i'm not mistaken
um because like i said i was a big dummy
and like watch this without even
realizing that it was a sequel to
something
so you know maybe have a double feature
uh
of the two movies if you're into
indonesian horror possession movies
and uh we will probably be back tomorrow
probably talk about that russian series
that we watched
um so you know because somebody
recommended that and we did actually
watch it and we haven't reviewed it yet
so we'll talk about that tomorrow and we
will see you
on the next one bye